قال بيني جانس عضو مجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي
ان التمزق الداخلي وقود يستغله الخصوم
وحذر من ان استبدال رؤوس الاذرع الامنيه
في زمن الحرب مضر بتماسك الجبهه
الاسرائيليه واشار جانس الى القتال في غزه
وبانه سوف يتوسع ويتصاعد وفق الحاجه وان
المراحل القادمه للقتال ستكون عميقه
ومفاجئه وجباره كما
يقول القتال في غزه يسير وفق الخطه التي
وضعها رئيس الاركان الانجازات تتسع
وتتراكم وهي غير مسبوقه مقارنه باي مناوره
بريه عسكريه في بيئه مركبه كهذا ثمه من
اعتقد ان الجيش الاسرائيلي لن يناور وليس
جاهزا والواقع يقول عكس ذلك قتلنا الاف
المخربين وضربنا قدرات القياده والسيطره
التابعه لحماس عززنا الدفاع وسوف نواصل
العمل في البنيه تحت الارض بدانا بقوه
والان علينا التصعيد والاستمرار والمراحل
المقبله للقتال سوف تكون جباره وعميقه
ومفاجئه